it'll be ustremski then dickerson and
brandon belt against marquez the
right-hander who's all warmed up
kashtremski on the ground as he
slips
and he'll be thrown out it's watch his
footing as he makes contact
and starts to head out and he just slips
an early scoring chance charlie blackmon
the hitter
and charlie drives it to right field
room for dickerson out there he'll make
the catch
david dahl tags and comes home easily
the rockies take a one to nothing lead
charlie blackman mr reliable it'll bring
another switch hitter to the plate in
the catcher tyler heinemann
and that is strike three on heinemann
second strike out of the evening for
hermann
one out that'll bring up brandon
crawford o2 set up away and there's 97.
i think that's the old good morning good
afternoon good night two outs oh two oh
three that's it
lead all singled by kung fu panda he's
left stranded
rocky's leading one nothing hermanos
already struck out ford
and another strikeout then you could
follow it up with
an 88 mile an hour slider so yeah i'd
have a lot of confidence too start the
fourth inning giants trail one-nothing
at coors field in denver here's the o2
see you later bell just walks off yeah
just dropped it in the subaru strike
zone six strikeouts already for
marcus so singled in a walk and here's
murphy
lined to right right at dickerson
i think murphy's claiming there was
catcher's interference let's see
that's exactly what you have you can see
the glove move
so that'll be an e2
on heinemann and the bases are loaded
nobody out one nothing rockies nobody
out bases
full and this is bounced up the middle
with top spin
and that's all they'll get is one so
matt
will get the rbi he hustles down the
first baseline two-nothing colorado sam
hilliard struck out his first time
another situational at bat here's the
pitch to hilliard swinging a drive into
right field and that'll be a base hit as
dickerson is there to play it but in
comes arenado rbi single sam hilliard
rockies three
giants nothing giants have run at first
and second after consecutive hits
duggar goes the other way hit well
on the move is hillyard at the wall it
is
we don't know
well i couldn't tell if it hit the top
of the fence and bounced back in third
base umpire who has the call is
wiggling his finger that's jim reynolds
it is a three-run homer this just kept
traveling
it didn't go out that did not go out
it hit the top of the fence that that is
going to be the two-run double here is
londoria who has popped up to second and
grounded out to third the pitch
line to a diving nolan arenado their
status quo nolan making a gold glove
play don't often see him being outdone
and that was a tremendous play arenado
saw it all the way that's another
marvelous play by nolan bottom six
rocky's up 3-2 aronado murphy and kim
hold on this ball's lied to deep left
and it does get out a long shot
that's stuck just to the right of the
347 elevated fence
4-2 colorado back-to-back ball games
with a homer for nolan marquez will go
after
the eight-hole hitter dubon here
right-handed batter swung on it missed
and her bond dispatches of dubai tony
walters will put the tag on as airmon
marquez does it again his eighth
strikeout of the game so the rockies
with a runner in scoring position and
two outs for blackman
and this is gonna drop story around
third throw to the plate nope not even
gonna offer charlie blackman makes it
five to two
on an 02 pitch with two outs gotta love
it
well you take advantage of the miscue
too by san francisco allowing trevor to
get to second base so this will be an
unearthed
one pitch away from his
first career save
2-2
on the ground to second
awakes to murphy ball game over the
rockies approved to 8-2 congratulations
to yetiel fonte
with his first career save
and here about marcus with his 40th
career victory as he goes an outstanding
seven and a third the rockies have won
the first two ball games of this
four-game set against san francisco